what what do you make about what's
what's happened here maya kalisko
uh just how i go
a little bit more than an hour ago
we don't know if maybe it's bomb or
racket
we not clear right now it's the expert
gives clear information
sitting
here
the huge
print from from
from this racket
actually
what is crazy
it's front of them freeze school
and
you see the damaged preschool
thanks guys nobody was in preschool and
school
six buildings
is damaged nobody can live in these
buildings
we equate right now the people
but
one more one more fact
is the war against civilians it doesn't
see military people here
it's no military base
it's a just apartment apartment from
civilians
against civilians
one one more example the russian
propaganda russians liar
what they explain about the some special
operation especially against ukrainian
military forces
this war against civilians against
ukraine ukrainian population if you look
in mario pal if you look in harke if you
look in other cities turning right now
where the civilian will be destroyed the
city will be destroyed i expect
the russians do it exactly the same way
how far do you think this will impact
the spirit of the kiev residents the
ukrainian people these constant attacks
against civilians this spirit
please talk to the people the spirit
and the will
to fight to give the answer
if russian things here people will be
will be
disappointed
it will be people will be impressed and
depressive is not
people want to fight and every day the
civilian asked me please mer
we need the weapons we're ready to
defend our families our houses and our
city
do you think there's any mistake this
could have been a mistake or was this
deliberately targeting civilians uh okay
if we're talking about mistake
his mistake
last
morning was a mistake 24 hours ago two
days ago was mistake huge mistake
destroyed the harketh and mariupol how
many mistakes they do it how many cities
have to killed and after that to explain
about mistake the
from from russian forces